I graduated high school at 10 years old
then I graduated from American River
College at 11
if I do an md/phd program it will
hopefully by the time I'm 18 so
brilliant convicted dinosaurs when I was
around five and I did a lot of
researches about dinosaurs
I felt that I've already learned all the
materials and so I felt like backing
from the parts parts I could learn more
a part of the first few classes my mom
with my classmate because the college
wasn't sure whether I'd be able to
handle it
lots of the students are little nice
towards me but then there's some that
are intimidated or jealous of me not
just studying all the time so I play
video games I like to watch movies in my
family
I want to become a doctor a medical
researcher and the President of the
United States